so i don't know how many of you saw or
remember the recent film with leonardo
dicaprio don't look up there's this
incredible scene where they bring on one
of the scientists who
um has discovered that there's this uh
comet or meteor i don't remember heading
towards earth and they say this is
happening it's going to kill all of us
and the news
of reporters who are
uh oh man i don't remember the actors
tyler perry and oh man i forgot now in
any case we're going to look at it they
say you know we want things to be
positive here like okay yeah right but
we're all going to die if we don't do
anything and they go no but it's we we
like positive news here and
yesterday on gb news in response to the
insane historic heat wave that is
plaguing much of the united states and
europe
there was almost the exact same sort of
discussion no we warm is nice we like
warm no
people will die no but it's it's so nice
when it's warm out we're going to look
here first ben phillips put this
together this is really good first it's
going to be the segment from the
satirical film don't look up
and then it'll be yesterday's segment
from gb news
and they're basically the same thing
are we not being clear
we're trying to tell you that the entire
planet is about to be destroyed
okay okay well it's um you know there's
something we do around here you know we
just keep the bad news light oh you see
john you're outside enjoying the
sunshine it's not too hot what is it
no it's it's absolutely lovely it's
about 20 degrees out here it's perfect
but um on a serious note folks um by
early next week
you can scrap 20 degrees it could well
be 40 degrees i think
there will be hundreds if not thousands
of excess deaths early next week shots
but like that's bad news you don't want
that in front of me are frightening
so we all like nice weather but this
will not be nice weather this will be
potentially lethal weather for a couple
of days it'll be brief but it'll be
brutal
so you know we can
oh yeah so this is so john i want us to
be happy about the weather and
everything i don't know whether
something's happened to meteorologists
to make you all a little bit fatalistic
and yes it's called the reality
harbingers of doom because all of the
broadcasts particularly on on the bbc
every time i've turned on anyone's
talking about the weather they're saying
that there's going to be
tons of fatalities but yeah i don't know
whenever i look at more reputable news
outlets than ours
they're acting like this heat wave is a
bad thing can't we just be happy about
the warmth we always had
hot weather
john i mean wasn't the 76 the summer of
76 that was as hot as this wasn't it
uh no
and you know we are seeing more and more
records more and more frequently and
more and more severely uh so yeah some
people always hop back to the summer of
76 which was a freak event 40 odd years
ago 40 years ago
but heat waves are becoming more extreme
this is yet another one which is coming
down the tracks towards us and you know
i don't think we should yeah so anyway
gb news is a right-wing channel backed
by discovery now discovery i mean
discovery's done really good stuff on
science and climate and so on um but
they are one of the backers as well as
some non-uk financiers for gb news
and i mean it's it's the same thing as
the scene from don't look up isn't this
nice it's sort of like the right wing
thing of listen trees like to breathe
carbon dioxide so isn't more carbon
dioxide a good thing and it has become
you know when when don't look up first
came out
it was a
it was like an extreme version
of this a barrier head in the sand sort
of trumpism a parody of trumpism
now
the scene we just saw from the real news
is as or more crazy
than uh what we saw in the film don't
look up it's truly bizarre stuff and uh
reality mirroring fiction at this point
in a really horrifying and scary way as
many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time-consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below